by the kids on the way over to enjoy  your video we're gonna guess that we're  gonna get the nudge when we have to get  him Angelina Jolie stunned on the red  carpet at the premiere of her new  historical thriller first they killed my  father  Angelina who directed and co-wrote the  film attended the premiere at the  Toronto International Film Festival  alongside all six of her kids including  Maddox impacts who worked on the  production excite you know I don't know  I think they're excited they're more  like mom they did have that like some I  think they were laughing at us actually  before really they were laughing at both  of us because they're they used to  seeing us like at home and then we hang  out pajamas and mcbrick so even though  they've seen me dressed up they really  laughed at her dressed  [Music]  you